you've heard me make some jokes earlier
at his expense you know he's a he's a
good sport about this
but he I don't know how recently but he
cut off the tip of his finger
in a cocktail accident
what cocktail were you making
all right fingerless Tommy come on down
Jared was giving this away I thought I
would share that um so I recently
defended my PhD and my
all of my dissertation notes are in one
of these that I got a couple years ago
so
fun fun little personal fact there
all right so uh as Jared said I keep
trying to get out of this uh so
originally when Jared and Nicole
approached me uh and said would you like
to speak at uh the conference coming up
I said no uh because I'm defending my
dissertation and I don't have time to
make a new presentation
and a few weeks later they said well
would you at least be a backup speaker
and I said yes but only on the condition
that you get a 20-minute version of my
dissertation defense because that is the
only presentation I'm going to make this
year
and then two weeks ago they said you're
on so
uh with that I wanna I wanna give
everyone here my apologies
um instead of an R talk uh you're going
to be getting some key points of what it
took me to get a PhD in computational
statistics
um I've tried to keep the math to a
minimum
uh there is uh an R tie-in though uh so
last year when we did this virtually uh
I presented on an r package called tidy
LDA and that's actually I've been
building it in concert with my research
so uh you know in addition to having
this package out on cran that you can
use this is now sort of the background
of of the underlying science that went
into some of the novel features or or
default settings for that for that
package
so uh with that
um language is uh an abundant and
information Rich data source it is
literally the protocol we use to convey
information to each other
and I dream of a world where we can
measure ideas and narratives uh with the
same level of scientific rigor that we
use to measure economic activity or the
effect of a medical intervention
but to do that we really need two things
um so the first is science
um and my dissertation was developing
some statistical theory for working with
languages data primarily through using
latent deer clay allocation I'll explain
why in a little bit
uh and then we also need tools and
methods that are intuitive and user
friendly because you want to make it
easy for practitioners to do something
in a principled way not everyone needs
to be able to follow the math and
re-implement it in uh code from first
principles themselves
so the the current generation of
language models you might have heard of
them they're called Transformers like
Bert's GPT uh there's a few other ones
um they work so well latent dear clay
allocation actually quick show of hands
who's heard of or used latent dirkley
allocation
I'd say maybe about a third of the room
here
um
it's that model is now 20 years old it
was developed so the paper was published
in 2002. so why am I still studying it
well there's a couple limitations to
this current batch of pre-trained
language models that have really been
taking the World by storm since 2017
2018.
first they're really task based they're
built for making chat Bots they're built
for summarizing documents tagging parts
of speech etc etc but what they aren't
fit for is making inferences on
populations from samples which is
obviously a core statistical task
second uh they're almost all deep neural
networks and so for all of the really
strong predictive power they bring the
complexity of a deep neural network is
makes it effectively a black box when it
comes to interpretability
and so I would really like to see text
analyzes enter the statistical
mainstream by focusing on what
statisticians do best not just building
better chat Bots although somebody needs
to do that too and so I've taken to
calling this natural language statistics
to differentiate it from natural
language processing which is this
inherently task based sub subfield of
artificial intelligence
foreign and so with the goals of natural
language statistics in mind uh Leighton
dirkland allocation has some pretty nice
properties it aids with interpretability
and quantification of uncertainty
because at its core it is embedding uh
language into a probability space which
is kind of all of how statistics works
um because it is just a Bayesian
statistical model we can lean on
established best practices to figure out
how to use it we don't need to reinvent
new statistics to figure out what are
some guiding principles to getting good
models
um and one of the most powerful things
is that um it models a data generating
process and so we can leverage that data
generating process to create simulated
data that can provide sanity checks for
developing new methods and metrics and
I'm going to talk a lot more about that
in a moment
uh so as a review for those that may
have used LDA before or for those that
it's new uh here's a quick intuitive
take so I have a collection of documents
those documents are full of words in
different frequencies
and what LDA does is it splits the those
documents up into two groups so you get
a collection of topics which are
themselves groupings of words that are
correlated
and then you get these simplified
documents that are now a collection or
distribution of topics
um and that can help you get a topical
similarity rather than just purely word
co-occurrence between these documents
these are represented by these variables
of interests beta and Theta respectively
um but because I told you this is a a
cut down version of a dissertation
defense we're going to get a little math
here sorry
uh so here's a more technical take
um
a researcher is interested in creating
Theta and beta and that's like what you
analyze at the end of the day what is
the distribution of topics what are the
distributions or words within these
topics
um but a researcher has three parameters
that they need to set up front uh one is
this thing called Ada it looks sort of
like an N but uh the tail on its long uh
there at the bottom right and that Tunes
this distribution over of words over
topics
uh then you have another one called
Alpha uh that is over on the the left
there and that Tunes the the
distribution of topics over documents so
there were what are called prior
parameters this is like what do I think
the world looks like and then I'm going
to update that with my data
then you also need to choose the number
of topics and if anyone has done any
reading on people that are using LDA uh
it's stack Overflow is full of people
that are like how do I know what number
to choose uh news flash uh nobody knows
good luck
um
most of the attention in the literature
has been on selecting K uh the second
most attention has been on selecting
Alpha but one of the the interesting
results of my research has been that uh
it seems like Ada is actually a much
bigger deal than Alpha when it comes to
tuning what uh results you get but
consistent with conventional wisdom it
seems like selecting the number of
topics is even more important and we're
still not sure how to do that
so I did uh three studies uh and I want
to summarize the key results here for
you really quick
um so LDA is is what's called a latent
variable model so that that Theta and
that beta I they're latent we don't see
them in real life and that's a problem
because uh no ground truth exists
against Switch we can compare our models
and methods it's just sort of good luck
this seems reasonable
um I feel like we can do much better
than that I felt that way for almost 10
years which is what set me on this
journey
um fortunately like I said before LDA is
a generative process so I can use that
process to create synthetic data sets
where I do know the ground truth I know
exactly what parameters were used to
generate my data and I can use that to
Aid in the development of methods and
metrics and so simulation studies like
that actually have a really rich history
in the statistical literature if you
read the LDA literature they're used
occasionally
but one of the big limitations to to
doing simulation studies with LDA is
that if your simulated data is going to
be valid then you need to be able to
create simulations that obey the the
gross statistical properties of human
language most notably it's something
called Zips law I'm going to talk about
a bit on the next slide
um that actually goes to the key
scientific contribution that I've made
being able to create simulated data that
conforms to Zip's law so now I argue
that the use of simulation studies goes
from uh what some other folks in the the
LDA literature called to uh uh toy
studies to this is something that is a
statistically rigorous way to study LDA
as a model of language so that that is
my key thesis here
um
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
that study where I went to establish
that so Zips law describes this
relationship between the frequency of a
word and its rank order
basically the most frequent word in any
Corpus in any language in any context is
roughly twice as frequent as the second
most frequent word the second most
frequent word is roughly twice as
frequent as the third and so on and so
on and so on going down the line to tens
or hundreds of thousands of words that
are in your Corpus
that relationship forms something called
a power law which is an extremely skewed
distribution
um but it is linear and log log space so
if you look at the middle and right hand
side graphic these are more or less
straight lines so that's because the Y
and the x-axis are logs of the the
original data
and so the bottom line of this graphic
is that if if this parameter Ada is
itself shaped like a power law then LDA
is going to generate word frequencies
that are consistent with zips law but if
ETA is not a power law LDA will not
generate word frequencies that are
consistent with Zip's law so that gives
us a very important constraint on if I
want to simulate data and I want to make
it look statistically like human
language this thing has to be has to
have this property
um
but you know I told you before that a
lot of the attention in literature has
been on this other parameter Alpha
the left and center of this have uh both
a power law Alpha and a symmetric Alpha
but the um
the leftmost graphic has a flat data and
the right or in the center graphic has a
power law Ada so you'll notice that is
not linear in log space but the middle
one is
uh the key here being uh Alpha this very
important parameter that people have
spent a lot of time on seems to be
irrelevant when it comes to shaping
human language that doesn't mean the
parameter itself is irrelevant but if if
I want to make something look like human
language uh it doesn't really add any
information here
and then on the right uh that was just
taking some simulated data in green and
calibrating it against uh real world
data in Orange and you can see that uh
at least the passing the eyeball tests
they're roughly the same shape
foreign so I wanted to examine how
different tuning parameters for this
data generating process can affect some
Corpus statistics and I wanted to see
what the effects of mispecifying these
parameters on an LDA model were so if I
intentionally chose the wrong parameters
because in real life you don't know what
the right answer is what is the effect
of that
so two different studies
to do that I generated over 4 000
synthetic data sets across a range of
parameters
and then for the first study I saw how
those parameters affected the resulting
word frequencies and for the second I
intentionally mispecified uh four
different LDA models and compared it to
against a perfectly specified LDA model
to see what the effects of mispecifying
individual parameters were
um I don't have time for the sake of
time to really get into like exactly
what uh these different statistics are
that are on the screen
um but you know I want to call out sort
of the the end result here so this is
looking at uh how these parameters
affected your Corpus properties
first is the magnitude of Alpha and I
also use the quadratic of it uh
basically have no effect on these
outcomes the top row you see there's a
variable with a gigantic confidence
interval uh that's that's the alpha and
so on the bottom row I just took it out
of the regressions and said you do not
matter uh and you can see that
um
uh K so the number of topics has a
pretty big effect on what you'll see
from the the resulting word frequencies
uh and Ada does as well uh as well as
things like the average length of your
document so it's basically like a proxy
for data size uh no no surprises there
and so for the misspecification study
um
I did uh roughly half of these
mispecified models no matter what
parameter I was uh mispecifying were too
big and roughly half were too small
again I'm not going to get into what all
of these outcome statistics are but
um I am going to talk about some of the
the key takeaways here so one is
mispecifying the number of topics seems
to have the biggest effect on your
model's performance so that thing that
everyone worries about uh that nobody
really knows how to set yeah it turns
out it super matters
um
one thing that was curious is that if I
intentionally must specify Ada to not be
a power law but to be flat for many of
these performance metrics that actually
seem to improve the fit of my model I
don't know why
um but you know that's that's fodder for
for future study
um consistent with my the results on the
previous slide misdomsifying Alpha does
not seem to really affect things at all
um that was surprising to me
um
and then uh you know one last thing is
that if you look at this one L coherence
here which I'm not going to describe
something called a coherence metric
which you may have heard of if you've
heard of LDA if not so I'll talk to me
about it after this the presentation
but you notice if K all the way on the
right there is too small or if it's too
big they're both negative
this is being compared to the Baseline
of a perfectly specified model so what
that tells me is if I get it right
I reach some sort of Maximum there
so that tells me that you know there's
some evidence that says this statistic
might actually be helpful at selecting
the number of topics uh unfortunately
that's a future study so I don't
actually know how to do it yet
um so synthesizing uh uh four key points
and highlighting three uh the biggest
one is we can use simulated data in a
principled way to now actually study
this model and develop some regular
statistical theory on how to use it
um next it looks like Alpha might be
over emphasized in the literature which
is a pretty startling result for the
sake of conservatism I will just say
that there's evidence to revisit uh uh
the conventional wisdom I'm not going to
say that I've overturned it uh and then
finally maybe that coherence metric can
help us choose the number of topics
so
um I've established we can use
simulations in a principled way to study
LDA and so the next two studies that I
did were using those primarily to help
develop in one case a new metric well a
new old metric we'll get into that uh
and then the other a slight modification
of the model in a way that I think is is
helpful to practitioners
um so this first is extending a
well-known statistic for goodness to fit
that's often used in linear regression
uh called the coefficient of
determination or or r squared
um so as a quick review r squared for
linear regression uh it goes between
zero and one it measures the proportion
of variance in your outcome variable
that were exp that was explained by your
model
so if it's one that means that your
model has explained 100 of the variance
in your outcome
uh it is a ratio of a sum of squares
which is the very bottom point there
um that's sort of an important fact to
understand the Insight that I had in
extending this to to work for
multi-dimensional outcomes which is uh
what a topic model models
um so the title here says it all
the traditional sum of squares is uh the
sum of squared euclidean distances take
my word for it but uh if you want to
look at the the formula I can point it
out to you and so I said well if it's
the sum of squared euclidean distances
in one space why can't I just extend it
to squared euclidean distance as an n
space so that's what I did
and this graphic depicts that in two
space right so uh to get a total sum of
squares you would just add up the
squared length of each one of the red
lines on the left there and to get a
residual sum of squares that would just
be the squared length of all the black
lines on the right graphic
so uh most notably this is the exact
same r squared from one ear regression
it's just used generalizing it to
outcomes and N Dimensions like a vector
of word frequencies which is exactly
what topic models model and this isn't
limited to topic models and Theory one
could apply it to deep learning models
of language too
uh the only a note I would give is that
this is now interpreted as the
proportion of variability in your data
explained by your model not variance
because variance is just a very specific
formula that I broke when extending this
to n space
uh so the bottom line is the same r
squared we all know and love all the
same caveats apply but it also means
that we have something that's a little
bit more accessible to an audience that
might be more familiar with linear
regression maybe coming from the social
sciences or from the digital Humanities
but may not be themselves quantitative
experts like statisticians or computer
scientists
okay so last study
um Power along nature of language uh
means that the central limit theorem
which you may or may not have heard from
of in a stats class takes a lot longer
to take effect so the Practical result
of that is that you need much much much
much much larger samples to be able to
get something that is representative of
your population
so for language that means I need a lot
of data
to have something that has decent
statistical power
but that actually provides a theoretical
justification for the use of these
pre-trained language models that have
gotten really popular over the last few
years
so there's been this paradigm shift in
natural language processing previously a
researcher like in most other areas
would take a data set that was theirs
they'd build one model on it
and then try and do some inference or
build a task and that worked you know
okay but it was kind of brittle and now
researchers are starting from these uh
pre-trained language models they're
calling them Foundation models and then
fine-tuning the parameters by
introducing their own data but that
Foundation model can be huge fit on
hundreds of gigabytes of text
they are massive
what I did is I extended LDA to enable
fine-tuning of these pre-train enabled
like that pre-trained fine-tuned
Paradigm for for light and deer play
allocation I'm not going to get deep
into the math here but the the gist is
you're basically using the weighted
posterior of your base model as a prior
for uh the model that you want to
fine-tune and this has been implemented
inside Elda which as I said I presented
last year and had some code examples
so I did a simulation study to study
this too to see if the models would
converge in probability to the true
topics
I see them out of time so I'm going to
wrap it up really quickly apologies
but this graphic is a visual of a single
model's posterior converging to the True
Values that were used to generate the
data as you introduce more data and
you're fine-tuning it
uh you know caveat Supply under certain
conditions
um
biggest takeaways are on the left here
but if I can emphasize a couple points
uh this wasn't just about creating a new
tool for LDA uh there's there's Theory
here like I said Zip's law justifies uh
uh using these pre-trained models uh
particularly for for language data
instead of just doing your own
uh and I would I want to move into a
world where we can establish scientific
rigor around the use of language data
so it's in an r package I don't have
time for the novel features nor am I
going to summarize the results but this
is how you can contact me if you'd like